so I uploaded this video this morning on
embargo and took it down and I'm
re-uploading this version of it so sorry
about the confusion for anyone who saw
it in your feed before it was up for
about two hours and uh two people had
commented that Alika did something that
I didn't know was possible so I just
wanted to re-upload the video to correct
that I know a bunch of you were like it
doesn't matter it does this doesn't make
a big difference but I don't want to
give anyone even slightly uh incorrect
information nor do I want to do that to
Bethesda so this will just have like a
little edit in it to further clarify
that point but here's the video hello
everyone I'm Milano Charles and welcome
to my channel where it is Starfield day
everybody happy Starfield day uh this is
the first of like several videos that I
will have up over this weekend if you're
not interested in this game I'm sorry I
promise I won't do it too much but a lot
today and my first video here is kind of
a down I'm aware of that um but it felt
like an important thing to address more
than anything uh something that I
realize a lot of people had
misunderstood based on the questions
that I got in the Q a from yesterday was
just there was some leaks surrounding
this in terms of how much you can
actually explore a planet
and
uh more than anything questions about
space exploration I'm just going to show
you um we're playing on Xbox series X
right now and yeah my webcam is
bigger than normal because this is a
video in which I am trying to convey
information rather than just Show
gameplay if that makes sense
for my gameplay videos I promised the
webcam is much smaller
I don't actually need to go on the ship
to fly you can't just take off the uh
you can just go into the the menu
um
so if I go here and I go to the map this
is where you generally pick where you're
going to fly to
I'm going to go back to the system this
is everywhere in
the current system that I'm in
you've got a bunch of You Know Places
across the star map that I can head to
but for now let's go to Seoul keep it
simple got an outpost there
and we're gonna fly to
Earth
we'll just go to my outpost on Earth
um all of these places that have little
symbols on them you can fly to
that's like an actual location that
exists I mean you can also I don't think
you could fly to Saturn that wouldn't
make sense right
set Landing Target set close to Satin
see what happens if I try and go to
Saturn I think it'll let me look at it
but I can't land on it
yeah so we're looking at Saturn
um which is a very cool and I feel like
the space stuff like looks awesome like
this is what just
currently in our solar system I was so
excited to get to be here for the first
time it's really neat
um obviously you can't land on a gas
giant that wouldn't make sense anyway
but one of the first things that I
wanted to try when I launched the
spacebot of the game was trying to like
fly into the Sun or fly into somewhere
like Saturn uh you can't
um no matter what I try to do
currently boosting towards Saturn 500
miles an hour whatever I will never get
any closer to Saturn and at first I was
like maybe it's just that my ship's not
fast enough I need to upgrade my ship
because um the one I'm showing you here
is Space level ship with no upgrades at
all
uh but no I could leave this like this
for two hours straight going in 150
miles an hour in-game and I will never
get any closer okay so this is the part
where I'm technically incorrect if you
travel for long enough and obviously it
would be an insane amount of time
they've gone for realism over like
actual space exploration gameplay for
here for sure it turns out you actually
can eventually get to a planet but you
will clip through it or at least that's
what one person has done only one that
we know of you will definitely never get
to a point where you fly to a planet and
are able to land on it they said that
ahead of time we already knew that
wasn't a thing but apparently if you fly
for a very very very very very very very
long time hours and hours and hours I
would think in One Direction you will
eventually clip through an image
effectively of a planet and there were
lots of people in the comments of the
original version of this video when I
first uploaded it saying like oh of
course you'd never get to the sun if you
fly for a small amount of time but I
think people were expecting that based
on the comments they got people were
expecting it to not be like realistic in
terms of like Earth hours that it would
take to get to earth if you're flying
from outer space a lot of people were
definitely expecting that you would be
able to fly to individual planets
um that would be a feature of this game
and the point of this video is
essentially that it is not really okay
back to the video sorry so again because
I can't actually travel places from that
menu and go back to yeah star map uh go
back to system
um let's go to Earth so I am now outside
Earth
um which does have stuff there's debris
I don't know if I can hit me I've never
I don't think I've ever been hit
um but yeah Earth has a bunch of debris
around it um there are some planets that
have ships there are other planets that
have little space stations that you can
dock onto which is pretty neat let me
try and hit something
cool
can't hit stuff confirmed but yeah like
you have like this little
section of map that is like a space Zone
um that you are stuck in you can't
really move very much you can only move
closer to other ships in combat um which
you just fly around in this 3D space or
closer to your little space station so
that's the thing that um I think a lot
of people have really misunderstood um
Okay so
let's land back on Earth again
uh
back over to Australia not that it
really matters where we land
here and you do have to do this every
time you have to pick up the map and and
select where you're Landing so then from
here
um it just I think it just generates a
map I did make a little Outpost here for
home a little sleeping bag
I'm just gonna run as far as I can in
One Direction
um just to show you what happens and
kind of show you what a planet looks
like what earth looks like obviously
pretty Barren out here
if you click the scan option you can get
like a bit of an idea
of things you might be able to scan or
resources you might be able to look at
but eventually I will get to a point
where I can no longer explore any
further
um you basically can only get a certain
distance away from your ship and
and um
once you have you'll hit an invisible
wall that tells you that you need to
effectively get back in the ship and fly
in order to see anything new
okay it took a pretty long time people
are concerned about this like I don't
feel like this is an amount of distance
that you are going to want to travel
very often but yeah my option now
is to fast travel back to the ship which
you can always do which I love or to
open the planet map which would still
effectively do the same thing and then I
could land on a different part of Earth
I can't just keep running forward but
yeah I basically just want to show you
guys how that works
um I'll go back to the ship
obviously has to be a cutscene sorry a
loading screen for that
and then you know take off again and
anywhere else that you want to go you
just got to go back into that star map
and pick another planet to travel to you
can travel straight to a landing point
if you want to or you can travel to that
outside space Zone but yeah that's
that's pretty much how it works I hope
this was clear enough I figured I would
just show you instead of
talking about it again
we've got all debris around
Earth here
you can swap to third person and
navigate this this is actually the only
one I've seen with debris
but there are plenty of planets that
have
many a different thing
let me come over here
it's a nice little rock you've got there
and that what is it that's the star yard
they call it if you travel to the star
yard
that gives us basically again so we've
got ships here at least right
that are flying around but then you'll
be able to dock on this which I'll show
you how that works quickly but again
this is technically a thing that's
physically in space that I can get
closer to
um and crash into if I want to
uh but to dock we just hit X
and you'll auto dock to it
but that is an example of like a space
section that actually does have other
stuff in it including other ships that
are flying around but yeah that's pretty
much it for this particular video where
I just wanted to Showcase this one thing
that I felt like people were seemingly
pretty confused about or had a lot of
questions about
um so it seemed to make more sense to me
to just physically show you rather than
uh
just talk about it
um of course we'll have q and up later
today at some point I'm not sure exactly
what time I'll have that one up first
hour gameplay video should also already
be up
um happy star Fielding everybody